i'm eternally grateful to the speaker uh
for reaching this not just the speaker
of the house of commons by the way the
speak of the house of lords because
there are two
members of the house of lords who are
also sanctioned
uh by china and um
i think it was the right thing to do i
mean it is an outrageous concept that uh
we who have been sanctioned as
parliamentarians for free speech
then another group of people decide to
invite the representative of the
government that has sanctioned us
to parliament and that would have been a
huge coup to the chinese government uh
for them to be able to say look you know
we're still welcome and they obviously
don't have much time for those who are
sanctioned so his standing up for free
speech in the mother of parliaments is a
critical moment and by the way it has
resonated all over the world we've had
comments coming back from people who are
enormously pleased that uh that we have
rejected china's attempt to undermine
the natural process
do you think bans work i mean a lot of
people would say you know george you're
particularly for senior politicians like
yourself is is better than moving to a
more hostile position
well of course we talked about the uk
government sanctioning some officials
who were
very demonstrably and very approvably
involved in the what i think is a
genocide taking place in xinjiang but
certainly uh human rights abuses on a
scale that is industrial
and they were sanctioned by the british
government but then the americans have
sanctioned them and more and most
countries in europe have done the same
so this isn't just the uk sanctioning
some
they've gone on also by the way the
chinese to sanction in return members of
the european parliament uh members of
certain parliaments in uh the european
union and us so we're not alone in this
and there are americans that are also
now uh sanctioned by china
so this is about china refusing to
accept any criticism or any observation
they won't let the u.n in to have a look
at what's going on in xinjiang
as with kovid we see how they cover up
everything that they don't like so you
know free speaking out in a in the
mother of parliaments is important
because it sends a message to many
around the world who do not have this
opportunity that actually there are
people standing up for them and hoping
to make sure that china eventually
is brought to heal on this so if we see
china as both threatening and oppressive
in practical terms what can we do about
it
well we can continue to be much stronger
diplomatically by saying to them this is
simply unacceptable and this will have
an impact on the way that we perceive
the chinese
but it's the government has really
imposed this you know they're
intriguingly you know they've occupied
the south china seas they've had
disputes of the border with the indians
and killed some indian soldiers they've
trashed the sino-british agreement
they're threatening taiwan on a daily
basis with invasion i mean you know any
other country in the world would uh
would suffer huge uh a program from the
world but because uh so much of the
developed world is now
dependent on china for their cheaper
goods and for their policies like
batteries and
electrical cars and all these things
which they now dominate we found
ourselves muted to a degree and so this
process that i and others engaged in is
trying to get
governments in the western world to come
together to recognize that this threat
posed by china is growing not
diminishing they have a plan to be the
largest military in the world now and
then to take back taiwan and they've
said that publicly so we need to look
again at where we place our business we
should be looking to develop countries
like india much more and work with them
doing the things that we do with china
right now and less dependent for example
nuclear industry here in the uk is far
too dependent and it's a strategic
industry communications were dependent
until we blocked huawei
i formed an organization with others
called the inter-parliamentary alliance
on china it's an international
organization now has 20 countries from
japan to the united states with
parliamentarians on the left and right
and growing and this is what upsets the
chinese more than else is that more and
more countries are coming together their
legislators are coming together and they
are wanting to stand together to say you
cannot bully your way through this you
have to become a proper functioning
member of the world order in that case
you have to stand by laws and rules in
trade and in human rights as well and
there's no escaping it and if you don't
we should be saying that we're going to
be moving our business elsewhere and
that is a progressive process which i
think would put huge pressure on